mein Thema ist tatsächlich wir leben in
der Demokratie und das wichtigste was
man in der Demokratie hat das
allerwichtigste was man in Demokratie
hat ist Vertrauen oder was man braucht
ohne Vertrauen funktioniert Demokratie
nicht wir müssen uns das ein Bewusstsein
wir müssen uns untereinander die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger müssen sich
untereinander einigermaßen Vertrauen man
muss dem anderen Bürger die Mitbürger
der Mitbürgerin zutrauen dass er
einigermaßen
gut abstimmt dass er einigermaßen
vernünftig sich Verhältnis einigermaßen
vernünftig Ansicht wir müssen auch den
staatlichen Institutionen vertrauen
können
demokratie heißt ja am Ende auch das ein
Gesetz verabschiedet wird den wir
gehorchen müssen jetzt mal und das auch
das ist ja auch gut so das muss ja auch
so dass zur Not auch mit Gewalt
durchgesetzt werden kann mit staatlicher
Gewalt statt gewaltmonopole Staates
dafür müssen wir aber das Vertrauen
haben dass die Politiker dass die
staatlichen Institutionen dass die
Parlamente das Gemeinwohl das
Allgemeinwohl im im Hintergrund drauf
haben nicht irgendwelche
Einzelinteressen zum Beispiel oder
klientelinteressen und so weiter das ist
wir müssen wir müssen das an die
Politikern vertrauen können wenn sie
sich in den letzten in den letzten
Jahren nicht erst seit Corona aber seit
Corona verstärkt anschauen wie sich das
Vertrauen der der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in den Staat in die staatlichen
Institutionen und in die Politik
entwickeln dann sehen sie ganz klar in
praktisch allen Bereichen geht's nach
unten und das ist alarmierend weil wenn
das wenn wir das nicht gestoppt kriegen
dann haben wir ein Problem auch für die
Demokratie weil ähm da haben wir auch
schon drüber gesprochen am Beispiel
Corona die da genau für die Demokratie
das dass ich immer mehr Leute inhaltlich
innerlich von der Demokratie abwenden
z.B das finden sie heute auch schon das
ganz wie gesagt na ja das ist doch alles
Quatsch was die machen die die die die
Arbeiten die eigene Tasche zum Beispiel
wir wissen ja gar nicht was im
Hintergrund noch es gibt auch seit
Corona da war Corona schon
eine Zäsur seit Corona gibt es wenn Sie
die Fragen Sie die normalen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger das ganz wie gesagt ja das
wissen wir ja alles gar nicht was die
uns da erzählen ob das überhaupt stimmt
wenn die Bürger anfangen das nicht mehr
zu glauben was in der Politik gesagt
wird und was als Begründung angeführt
wird für bestimmte Gesetze dann ist die
Demokratie irgendwann am Ende weil
nämlich die Bürger dann irgendwann nicht
mehr mitmachen
Politiker denn die Zahlen sind
tatsächlich alarmierend nur noch 37%
haben Vertrauen in den Bundestag nur 17
% Vertrauen den politischen Parteien
Herr alt können Sie diesen
Vertrauensverlust nachvollziehen was
läuft da falsch das ist dramatisch also
ich finde wir müssen vor allen Dingen
viel viel mehr zuhören und ich gebe
ihnen sehr recht der Professor dass sie
wenn sie Bürger haben die einem System
nicht mehr Vertrauen in der Demokratie
nicht mehr Vertrauen funktioniert auch
das ganze Land irgendwie nicht mehr und
ich habe nun die Ehre in dieser
Wahlperiode den flächenmäßig größten
Wahlkreis der Bundesrepublik zu
vertreten der zweieinhalb Mal so groß
ist wie das gesamte Saarland also ich
habe wirklich viel Fläche viele
Gemeinden 700 Dörfer und das versuchen
wir jeden Alltag zuzuhören wir fahren
also mit einem mobilen Bus durch die
Dörfer wo sonst niemand hinkommt wir
hören zu letztendlich veröffentliche
zweimal im Jahr auch meine Telefonnummer
an der Zeitung also letztendlich könnte
jeder Bürger hier auf diesem Handy
anrufen was hier neben mir liegt weil
mir das wichtig ist weil ich auch sage
wenn ich hier in Berlin der Vertreter
der Bürger bin dann muss ich wissen was
die Menschen bewegt in meiner Region es
bewegt die Menschen das Erzählen die
Ihnen wenn Sie anrufen na die Menschen
natürlich der ukraine-krieg dass sie
sich Sorgen machen darüber vor einer
Eskalation
die Leute die Menschen bewegen niedrige
Löhne niedrige Renten Altersarmut die
Menschen bewegt dass sie auf dem
ländlichen Raum keine
Verkehrsverbindungen haben um weg oder
hinzukommen dass sie dort quasi gefangen
sind auch ein schlecht ausgebautes
Mobilfunknetzen sind alles Themen meiner
Regionen die mir immer wieder begegnen
jeden Tag unter höre ich zu und versuche
dann eben auch wichtige Aspekte einfach
einzubringen Debatte denn hier in Berlin
ist ja so dass jeder dieser 299
Wahlkreise ein Stückchen Deutschland ist
und zusammen ergeben wir diese Farben
Deutschland letztendlich und wenn bei
mir im Hinweis viele Menschen für 1.300
1400 Euro netto 50 Kilometer einfach zur
Arbeit fahren dann sind die von höheren
Spritpreisen in weit höherem Maße
Betroffene Pumpe die Sie vielleicht bald
brauchen zum Beispiel wesentlich mehr
betroffen auch finanziell und das
vielleicht gar nicht stembar als eine
Region wo ich 4000 Euro netto
Durchschnittslohn habe Nase und deshalb
ist es wichtig ist all diese
verschiedenen unterschiedlichen Dinge
dass ich die höre und die dann auch eben
hier einbringen wenn Sie relevant sind
Sarah wir hören jetzt von einem
Politiker der sogar seine Telefonnummer
veröffentlicht du hast mit vielen
Politikern zu tun bis da ganz nah dran
hast du das Gefühl dass da dennoch viele
in so einer Art Bubble leben dass sie
die Bodenhaftung den Kontakt zu Menschen
zu den Wählerinnen und Wählern irgendwie
auch verloren haben Kompliment sie sind
wirklich nah dran sie verstehen auch
diese ganze Komplexität dass der Bürger
nicht eine Sorge hat sondern das
tatsächlich immer mehr dazu kommen ich
mein Corona Krieg Krise Klima
Flüchtlingssituation ich meine äh es
kommen wirklich eine Krise nach der
anderen und wir haben immer mehr sorgen
die wachsen und vor allem das
Finanzielle spielt immer eine Rolle und
ja es gibt Politiker die haben das total
im Blick ph-art und natürlich gibt
Kollegen auch ja und dann gibt es
natürlich auch welche die das eher nicht
so gut im Blick haben oder vielleicht
auch das nicht so ein Blick haben wollen
gerade so was die flüchtlingskrise
betrifft dass man da eher wegschaut
viele unschöne Bilder und vor allem das
jetzt auch das Vertrauen singt oder die
Akzeptanz das finde ich ganz schrecklich
von Asyl und Menschenrecht das finde ich
auch sehr bedenklich und da müssten die
Politiker eigentlich also müsste alle
Alarmglocken läuten wir müssen was
ändern wir müssen die Bürger mehr ernst
nehmen mit ihren Sorgen direkt auch
erreichen ja sogar auch die
Telefonnummer hinterlassen wenn sogar
sein muss man muss jetzt nah an den
Bürger dran sein weil sonst schwer
spielt man das Vertrauen und dann kann
es auch kippen dann gehen auch Menschen
andere Richtungen schlagen ein wie wir
es bei Corona gesehen haben Richtung
Verschwörungstheorien und dann wird es
auch gefährlich ehrlich gesagt wenn es
um Antisemitismus um Rassismus geht weil
wenn Akzeptanz sinkt sinkt Akzeptanz
auch gegenüber anderen Gruppen ja Herr
Dr Frank fallen ihnen abseits von Corona
Themen ein die sie verantwortlich machen
für den Vertrauensverlust der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in die Politik
also ich denke es ist schon ein bisschen
ein Problem wer geht heute in die
Politik und ich ich bevorzuge eigentlich
ein System wo jemand im Beruf seine Frau
oder seinen Mann gestanden hat auf
Berufserfahrung hat Lebenserfahrung hat
und dann eine gewisse Zeit in die
Politik geht aber das ist ja heute nicht
mehr der Fall sie machen heute eine von
Anfang an der Politik Karriere ich
glaube sie sind Ausnahme wann sie
Berufssoldaten ich bin Berufsoffizier
habe auch einen Einsatzerfahrung aber
kann Ihnen sagen dass wir im Bundestag
in meiner Fraktion von den 106 9
Kollegen also wir sind 100 vier neue und
102 alte tatsächlich so davon
abfallmeister bis zum Investmentbanker
Technologien immer alles dabei haben
also wenig Studienabbrecher ne
aber das gilt nicht für den gesamten
Bundestag das mag vielleicht für ihre
Fraktion gehen das gilt aber nicht für
den gesamten aufgemacht ja natürlich
klar aber wir reden ja über das
Parlament insgesamt und über das
Vertrauen ins Parlament insgesamt wenn
der 23-Jährige Studienabbrecher sitzen
und sagen liebe Rentner dann fahrt nicht
dreimal im Jahr nach Mallorca in Urlaub
dann habt ihr auch genug Geld für die
Wärmepumpe wenn sowas passiert ist weiß
ein bisschen überspielt aber wenn sowas
passiert
dann ist völlig klar dass man sich von
der Politik abwendet oder jedenfalls von
der Politik nicht mehr ähm repräsentiert
wird das ganz wichtig war glaube ich
auch das was Sie gesagt haben nämlich
dann wenden sich die Menschen die sich
von der Demokratie ab wenn die wenn sich
dann woanders hin die gehen ja nicht nur
nach Hause und machen gar nichts mehr
sondern die wählen dann ganz andere
Parteien das ist dann wir machen dann
ähm ja gar nicht mehr
wir machen mehr und wir machen dann auch
Platz für Populismus für unsere
Extremismus das ist der Punkt
ich habe jetzt viele Politiker
kennengelernt und ich habe eigentlich
nur eine ich ganz den Namen auch nicht
nennen ich habe nur eine kennengelernt
die wirklich antizipiert hat was man
sagt
es verarbeitet und danach fragt ich die
allermeisten die ich kennenlernen sind
in ihrer Geschichte in ihrem narrativ
was nutzt mir ja was bringt mich
vorante verteilt man doch oder will die
dann kein Kompliment mit den Kollegen
nicht und der habe ich erklärt dass wir
tatsächlich zu viele Intensivbetten
haben und sie hat es antizipiert und
jetzt verstanden z.B also ich nehme sie
als sehr sehr glaubwürdig war also ich
wir kennen uns ja nicht aber so sie
würde ihn also in meinem Wahlkreis würde
ich Ihnen jetzt mal zuhören ja aber ich
habe ihn gerade gesagt es gibt eine
offizielle Analyse der
krankenhausbelegungen die ist wasserfest
die ist nicht zu veranstanden ich würde
von ihnen eigentlich erwarten dass sie
sagen Herr Frank zeigen sie die mehrmals
und nicht antworten meine Ärzte meine
Wahlkreis und da waren die Särge und da
waren die Coron Patienten Schlange
gestanden sondern ich habe ihn an einer
hochwertige Information angeboten und
sie konnten sie nicht antizipieren
machen sie vielleicht noch aber das was
ich das nachher nochmal nachlesen
und dann sind wir in der Kommunikation
und das und das vermisse ich in der
Politik aber ich möchte mal noch eins
sagen in der corona-krise ist mir eines
klar geworden nicht die Demokratie
sichert unsere Freiheit es ist der
Rechtsstaat während
also mir kommt vor allen Dingen darauf
an als Bürger dass mich der Rechtsstaat
für den mächtigen also auch der Politik
schützt also auch wieder durchgeknallten
Regierung die die ich so empfunden habe
während der coronazeit und ähm also
insofern kommt mir auch darauf an für
Glaubwürdigkeit der Politik inwieweit
hält sich die Politik an die Gesetze und
wenn sie Übertritt inwieweit wird ein
Staatsanwalt aktiv und jetzt kommt das
ist meine grundsätzliche Kritik an der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
Staatsanwaltschaft ist weisungsgebunden
an Justizministerium das hat der EU
gehabt europäische Gesetze sagt uns
Bundesrepublik sorry er hat ein Problem
mit der Gewaltenteilung mit dem
Rechtsstaat nicht wir müssen nicht nach
Polen deuten im Finger wir haben ein
Problem wenn jetzt ein Staatsanwalt
dahinter kommt und sagt okay ich ja mit
normal in einem Corona haben Politiker
Verbrechen begangen kriegt dann Anruf
vom Justizministerium sagt Stopp
da haben wir ein Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
das müssen wir klären
Ermittlungen gegen Politiker gehabt und
wir haben die letzten Wahlperiode gehabt
die haben dazu geführt dass wir zum
Beispiel unsere ganzen
transparenz-pflichten komplett verändert
haben dass sie jetzt nachlesen können
auf den Cent genau was sie da Politiker
an Nebenverdienst ist
verboten sind der offensichtlich war
noch der damaligen Rechtslage dieses
sehr sehr moralisch verwerfliche
Verhalten eben erlaubt und es gibt auch
es gibt auch eine ehemalige Minister die
auch vor Gerichten standen wegen
Korruption und so weiter also ich glaube
der Rechtsstaat funktioniert ganz gut
und er gehört auch zu Demokratie ja also
sie haben völlig Recht der dem äh der
Rechtsstaat gehört zu Demokratie und sie
haben auch recht das was sie geschildert
haben war aber die Theorie des
Rechtsstaats so sollte der Rechtsschutz
sein und so will ist das Grundgesetz die
Verfassung eigentlich auch nach meiner
Einstellung hat das aber zeitweise in
der corona-pandemie nicht funktioniert
zum Beispiel weil es nicht reicht wenn
man sagt wir haben unabhängige Gerichte
die nichts befürchten müssen die können
ja urteilen wenn die Richter Angst haben
wenn die Person wenn die Person nicht
stimmen wenn ich
aber vielleicht auch ein extremer
Einzelfall
bestrafe einziehe viele ganz klar
wir sind uns ja auch einig das Problem
war finde ich der Ton wurde gesetzt vom
bundesverfassungsrecht dass die ganze
bundesnotbremse einfach so durchgehungen
hat ich habe die Urteile analysiert ähm
das ist mit Floskeln alles abgelegt
worden was in diesem Gesetzen drin stand
im November im November 2021 diese diese
bundesnotbremse zum Beispiel also um die
um die gings da wurde der Ton gesetzt
wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht als
aller Oberst das Gericht dass sie
Leitlinien festlegt wenn das sagt alles
in Ordnung wir haben keinen
verfassungsproblem damit dann reagieren
die anderen Gerichte ähnlich und gucken
auch nicht mehr kritisch und da war das
Problem also das Problem ist nicht der
einzelne Amtsrichter sondern der
vielleicht dann unter Druck gesetzt wird
noch zum Beispiel den Fall von Weimar
kenne ich auch haben sie recht ähm
es ist nicht der Einzelrichter sondern
das ist das System nämlich der oberste
Teil dieses Systems der Kopf sozusagen
der der juristische Kopf nämlich das
Bundesverfassung die sind Entdeckung
gegangen und das ist das das ist das ist
das rechtsstaatliche Problem was ich
sehe bei Corona jemand sitzt der Freund
des Grundgesetzes
Grundgesetzes sitzen also ich muss ihn
da wirklich erheblich widersprechen und
ich glaube wirklich es mag zwar sein
dass es eine gewisse Tendenz mal gab
quasi sich auf einer Linie ein bisschen
zu einigen aber ich glaube das ist beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht das hat schon
weiterhin sehr differenziert geurteilt
das hat eben auch gesagt
ja auch Grundrecht gegeneinander
abgewogen hat ja auch weil es hat gesagt
machen sollte da sehen wir uns völlig
ein das ist die Aufgabe in der lange
Geschichte noch zumindest hier
unterschiedliche Auffassung ich muss an
dieser Stelle einmal kurz zum
Durchschnaufen anregen wenn wir machen
eine ganz kurze Pause wir sind gleich
wieder hier freue mich wenn Sie bei uns
bleiben dann schauen wir nicht ganz
genau darauf was der Koalitionsausschuss
gerade so macht bis gleich wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie